ich hatte vor zwei tagen in den
interessanten abend mit rund 20
geflüchteten die in der ausbildung
gemacht habe abgeschlossen haben und die
jetzt teilweise nicht arbeiten können
das haben wir die betriebe da waren die
inhaber mit dabei sagt wir haben jetzt
die leute ausgebildet und bin jetzt
dürfen die nicht arbeiten gefragt warum
und der grund ist erfolgen denn es gibt
die so genannte drei +2 regel das heißt
drei jahre ausbildung da darf man zwei
jahre bleiben braucht dafür aber einen
neuen aufenthaltstiteln hat eine duldung
für die ausbildung und zwei jahre
anschließen kann man den
aufenthaltstitel bekommen dafür muss man
aber nachweisen dass man diese
ausbildung gemacht hat nicht so
schwierig aber jetzt kommt es ist
einfach deutsche bürokratie bevor das
ausländeramt es bei der stadt tübingen
sitzt dann diese aufenthaltsgenehmigung
aussprechen darf muss noch die
bundesagentur für arbeit zu stimmen und
was macht die die prüft ob die tätigkeit
ihrem arbeitsvertrag der personen die
jetzt eine ausbildung erfolgreich
abgeschlossen hat bei der firma der
ausbildung auch entspricht oder ob da
womöglich irgendwelche qualifikations
differenz liegt sind und nur um diese
kleine sicherheit zu haben dass jemand
der krankenpflege gelernt hat jetzt
nicht als fliesenleger arbeitet dafür
brauchen die dann halt weder vier bis
sechs wochen ergebnis da sitzen leute
sind fertig ausgebildet kriegen jetzt
kein aufenthaltsbewilligung zu kriegen
ein arbeitsverbot und vor allem wieder
in den leistungsbezug wäre die betriebs
sagen ich brauche ganz dringend diese
arbeitskraft und so macht deutschland
halt immer noch seine eigene zukunft wie
ich finde kaputt das ist doch absurd das
wird der arbeitskräftemangel mangel
leiden und dann haben wir fachkräfte
ausgebildet das persönlich arbeiten nein
das verwundert es natürlich nicht was
sie erzählen wenn er die erfahrungen der
der bewältigung der krise nimmt dabei
auch die bürokratie der heimliche regent
aller halaf erfahrungen aller verfahren
und ich glaube die bürokratie wird hier
die kurse für deutschland noch überleben
das ist leider traurig und wir sehen ja
dass wir die migrations krise vielleicht
stehen wir am vorabend einen neuen wenn
man die zahlen hört auf zwei seiten
momentan dabei sind schlecht zu managen
einerseits leute mit bleibeperspektive
die bereit sind sich zu engagieren and
wird das leben schwer gemacht dadurch
wird auch im osten höre ich dass dadurch
wird also unternehmern es erschwert
arbeiter zu finden die arbeitsfähig sind
und ausgebildet und andererseits werden
leute die auf absehbare weise keinerlei
bleibeperspektive haben keine
integrationswillen keinen bildungswillen
sondern die eher bereit sind hier das
gemeinwesen auszunutzen den wird ein
persilschein für langes bleiben hier
ausgestellt das heißt wir sind mal
wieder im reden moralischer weltmeister
und im handeln sind wir bürokratischer
absolut herrscher ich würde gerne eine
sache verstehen angela merkel hat vor
einigen jahren den satz gesagt wir
schaffen das und wir schaffen das ohne
jetzt zu viel philosophie da rein
interpretieren zu wollen muss man
eigentlich zwei dinge schaffen man muss
dafür sorgen dass die menschen die hier
nicht hingehören die wir nicht hier
haben wollen dass die abgeschoben werden
und menschen die ein recht haben
hierzubleiben dass sie integriert werden
und dass integration arbeit benötigt das
ist ja das liegt ja auf der hand da muss
man jetzt ja nicht fünf jahre lang herum
experimentieren damit dann irgendwann es
klickt man klick macht man merkt wenn
jemand einen job macht dann hilft das
ihm warum funktioniert politik hier
nicht also sich dass er gelernt wie die
bürokratische erklärung haben sie schon
gegeben um ehrlich zu sein ich halte es
auch nicht auf dem schirm weil das
dauert drei jahre bis die fertig sind
das heißt problem hatten wir noch nicht
und ich hab einfach nur lesen
flüchtlinge ja auch schon nicht erst
seit 2000 war aber es gab ja immerhin
eine bewegung dieser drei +2 regelungen
die ist neu die gab es früher nicht also
ich dachte okay jetzt haben sie es
endlich kapiert lasst die leute ihre
ausbildung machen dass sie zwei jahre
arbeiten können sie bleiben weil ich
finde wenn sich jemand hier bewährt und
sprache gelernt haben ist mir egal wo
daherkommt hat keinen sinn eine
fachkraft abzuschieben nach fünf jahren
im land wenn dann der betrieb sagt wieso
lehrjahres wie soll ich jetzt mein
auftrag annehmen so und ich dachte das
problem ist gelöst und jetzt das ist
halt praxis im rathaus jetzt habe ich
die leute vor mir und sagen hey problem
ist nicht gelöst ihr habt das
bürokratisch so blöd aufgezogen dass es
gar nicht sein kann dass jemand gerade
seinen abschluss macht und dann die
arbeitsagentur die chance hat es zu
prüfen ob das mit arbeits frage was kann
weil ich will ja lückenlos
zwischenabschluss und
weiterbeschäftigung weitermachen können
einfach bürokratischer unfug ich würde
auch diese prüfung verzichtet man die
arbeitsrecht anderes zu tun als zu
überprüfen ob der betrieb jetzt da
könntest dich selber überlegen aber
irgend ein bürokrat wahrscheinlich er
aber aber die arbeitsagentur muss doch
niemanden muss doch nicht im betrieb die
überlegung nehmen wir die
qualifikationen die demokratie und der
ausbildung erworben habe auch nutzt oder
operieren hat sowas anderem einsetzt es
sollte der betrieb in schreiben an das
sind ja sehr interessant diese in die
sie darstellen ich glaube dass das
stimmt 100 prozent oder dass sie das der
meine wahrnehmung von deutschland auch
sie aber eine unglaubliche
hirte byzantinische walz bürokratie und
ich muss aber sagen die leute die in der
bürokratie arbeiter sie meistens hoch
beeindruckende kluge menschen aber das
ist ja das problem die die von ihrer
eigenen von ihnen geschaffenen
komplexität zum opfer jetzt aus der
schweiz machen wie eine andere erfahrung
wir haben hier wir haben ja noch eine
viel höhere zuwanderung gehabt auch im
bereich des asylwesens als deutschland
das muss man einfach mal festhalten über
die letzten 10 15 jahren das hat bei
euch einen online tool hat einen kick
gegeben 15 ist das natürlich
hochgeschnellt da war die vermutlich pro
kopf der bevölkerung höher aus der
schweiz werden gigantische zuwanderung
unter dem bereich auch dass die
asylgesuche unsere regierung habe
versucht diese leute die man sich auch
das schön geredet hat das seien alles
fachkräfte was sie nicht wahr haben wir
eine so genannte flüchtlings lehre
eingeführt um diese auszubilden und da
ist die erfahrung dann aus dem privaten
sektor sehr ernüchternd ausgefallen also
dass eben doch viele diese leute nicht
die qualifikation mitgebracht haben das
kann ich nicht beurteilen visier ist das
war bei uns das war bei uns die die
thematik und was wir einfach da
diskutiert haben wir immer das thema das
wie gesagt haben das grundproblem in
dieser ganzen migrationsgeschichte ist
dass die schiene asyl und die schiene
arbeitsmigration miteinander vermischt
werden iris diese beiden kanäle nicht
getrennt werden weil die erfahrungen aus
früheren jahren wenn ich zum beispiel
flüchtlinge aus ungarn mehr flüchtlinge
als andere länder meine frau ist
vietnamesen die ist über den
südvietnamesischen die mussten fliehen
vor der nordvietnamesischen
die schweiz gekommen die musste man
nicht zum arbeitsplatz und die muss dann
richtig die schulen schieben sich die
regierung sie haben
die haben sich
ja was heißt es sind einfach erfahrungen
ich weiß nicht wann ich rede nicht viel
denn ich werde mit erfahrungen und ich
habe einfach den eindruck dass heute ist
das problem diese verschiedenen
migrations schienen vermischt werden und
man versucht etwas die symptome zu
bekämpfen und das resultat ist ein
bürokratischer uwe kellner wie schnell
kriegt jemand in der schweiz ab also bei
meint bild ich habe damals auch beim
handelsblatt auch öfter damals euro die
flächen / epa damit auch mal
flüchtlingszahl mein bild war das nie
dass die leute in arbeit geschoben
werden mein bild war immer dass
flüchtlinge arbeiten wollten aber
dürften okay dann gab es keine arbeit
navarro hast du erst mal monatelang um
flüchtlinge seien ja aber es geht es in
den bereits schneller und sie sich man
muss eben aufpassen diese thematik ich
halte das für hoch relevant aber wenn du
natürlich das signal aussenden ist in
die welt dass man zum beispiel in
deutschland oder in der schweiz wenn du
über das asyl reinkommst viel schneller
einen job findest dann löst damit
natürlich auch eine weitere so und
magnet wirken offen da sich vielleicht
etwas die problematik bei ihrem ansatz
wenn sie sagen wir eher leicht und die
möglichkeit in den arbeitsmarkt zu gehen
ungewollt sendet man das signal hat ja
eine lösung noch mehr kommen jetzt der
analysen will sie die ehefrau nicht
sehen sie die gefahr nicht
es muss man für die zukunft muss man
dieses angebot nicht machen weil da gibt
es dieses problem das ihn beschreiben
aber jetzt haben wir anderthalb
millionen menschen im land von denen wir
wissen dass die deutsche bürokratie sich
selber so verstrickt dass sie davon wie
keine abschieben die werden bleiben also
aber eine tatsache kann man gut finden
oder nicht aber dann ist es doch behält
diese leute irgendwie da in abhängigkeit
und in arbeitslosigkeit zu schicken wenn
man die chance hat und die wollen nicht
alle wollen manche wohl neben doch die
arbeiten zu lassen so dann sage ich es
nenne ich spurwechsel ist es mir lieber
die gehen aus dem asylverfahren raus und
wechseln in die
arbeitsmarkt einwanderung das sind die
hat sozusagen aus deutschland
eingewandert in den arbeiten waren ja
aber wenn sie schon da sind und schon
alles gelernt haben doch blöd die
scheiben zu schicken und dafür einen
anderen zu holen das risiko diese songs
aus es besteht natürlich darin dass dann
die asyl schiene als einstieg in den
arbeitsalltag noch weniger haben sie
doch nun den stichtag sagte das gilt nur
für reiche die bis zum ersten januar 20
da gewesen also wir werden sehen ob es
funktioniert wir sie beobachten dass
wenn es gut ist dann kommt aber erst
einmal das was sie gesagt haben wenn man
die deutsche bürokratie kennt da muss
man sagen davon wird kaum jemand
abgeschoben das ist doch der satz der
für die sogwirkung sorgt das ändert sich
auch nicht mit einem stichtag stimmt
aber dann hat es mit meiner lösungen
auch nichts zu tun dann ihre lesbischen
plötzlich meine lösung kein problem weil
die kein neues schafft dann ist ja auch
gut aber darf ich mal eine frage stellen
warum wird eigentlich in deutschland
viel zu wenig ausgeschöpft es gibt
gesetze das muss sie auch mal konnte ich
heute nicht einfach bei einem brand in
seinem haus einziehen und haben sich
wohl jetzt bei ihrer beute dann werde
ich ja auch ausgestopft aus ihrem aus
wie sowas boden krank wieso kann man
nicht einfach leute deren asylbescheid
abgelehnt wurde wieso werden die nicht
so wir können und auch eine antwort bei
dem thema zu lassen die gebe ich jetzt
herr palmer es war sein thema warum
werden nicht
weil das gesellschaftlich von der
mehrheit nicht gewollt ist weil man sich
in bürokratischen fallstricken verfängt
und weil es auf eine verfestigung des
aufenthaltsstatus gibt wenn leute viele
jahre da sind und wir hatten so viele
auf einmal dass man die verfahren
zwangsläufig nicht in kurzer zeit
abschließen konnte nach sieben jahren
zieht die welt einfach anders als wenn
einer drei monate das wäre meine
erklärung